I have genuinely never been as
productive as I am right now because of
Claude's skills. This image really does
sum it up. I feel like I'm working on
multiple different computers and
multiple different tasks at the same
time without sacrificing quality. It
just comes down to one simple word and
that is leverage. With Claude skills or
any agent skills for that matter, you
have way more leverage than if you were
doing this by yourself. So, in this
video, I'm going to be breaking down
what skills are, how they work, and how
you can build really, really good ones,
even if you've never heard of the
concept or built a single skill ever
before. So, let's hop into a live demo
real quick and get going. All right, so
here we are in Claude Code in my Herk 2
project, which is kind of just like my
personal assistant. Now, if this stuff
over here looks overwhelming, don't
worry about that right now. Just worry
on what I'm actually asking the agent to
do. So, I've got the skill that I called
morning coffee that helps me plan my day
every morning. So, it's not morning
right now, but I'm going to run this so
you can see how it works. So, as Cloud
Code's figuring that out, what I'm going
to do is open up another agent. And in
this one, I'm asking it to run a pulse
check on all my projects and commitments
to see how things are going. I'm opening
up another one to create me an Excal
diagram of the difference between local
AI models and closed source models. And
let's just do one more that's going to
scrape the comments from my recent
YouTube videos and give me an analysis
on what I need to improve. So what
you're looking at right now is four
different agents running in parallel
doing things for me. And that took me
probably 30 seconds to ask them to do
that. And because I built all of these
skills, all of these agents have all of
the context about my business, what's
going on with our projects, my YouTube
channel. It has literally everything it
needs. And now all of those agents are
done. Here was my February 26th morning
coffee. I had three things on the
calendar. So, what it's going to do is
it's going to look at my ClickUp. It's
going to see what else I've got this
week and look at my tasks and then help
me plan the rest of my day. So, this is
the plan that it suggested. All I have
to do is say, "Yep," and it would block
off everything for me. And for me,
that's huge because I don't have
decision fatigue anymore of what I have
to work on. The second agent came back
with a pulse check, 2 days until the end
of the month. Here's where everything
stands. So, obviously I'm going to blur
all of this out, but it's basically
catching me up on all of the different
main initiatives that we're doing this
month and this quarter and making sure
that everything is on track. And right
here, you can see there's a few things
that I need to follow up on manually.
And this might have slipped through the
cracks because I'm so busy making
YouTube videos if I didn't have this
personal assistant to check up on me
using the skill. The third agent came
back and has finished the Excal diagram
and I pasted it in and it looks like
this. So, if I needed to make a video
about this, I wouldn't have had to take
my own time to create this
visualization. So, for the comment
analysis, that came back and we can see
all of the comments, all the views, and
things that I need to address either in
future videos or in the comments. We got
some confusion. We've got some cost
things that I need to cover. We have to
stop demoing toy examples for tool
videos. Seems like you guys really want
to see some anti-gravity stuff. I
promise that'll come soon. And then
we've got top three priorities. So, I've
been recording now this video for about
6 minutes. Just think about if I would
have done all four of those things
myself, how much context switching I
would have done and how long that would
have taken me. Okay, so now that you
guys have seen an actual demo, and
hopefully you're a little bit excited to
learn about Cloud Skills if you haven't
used them yet, what actually are they?
So, skills are reusable instructions.
You write them once, you save them as a
skill. You can trigger them anytime, and
you're going to get way more consistent
results because it's going through that
same process every time. So, this visual
right here was actually an AI generated
image that I used with a skill. It was
this one right here in my Cloud Code
called Excalibraw visuals. But sometimes
with AI generated images, they don't
spell words right. As you can see here,
this is all messed up. This stuff is
messed up. So, I also have one, as you
saw in the demo, to create Excalaw
diagrams. And this one creates the
actual Excal that I could move and edit.
And the words are always perfect because
it's actually just typing. And those two
skills alone have saved me so much time.
And what I'm going to do, by the way,
for all you guys, is in my free school
community, the link for this is down in
the description, I've added a new
classroom section called agent skills
where I'm just going to be dropping a
ton of these skills that you guys can go
grab for completely free. So, before we
dive into this today, just real quick,
why should you care? And there's three
big reasons. You can be way more
productive as a person because you can
automate things like you just saw me do.
And you can legitimately build a
personal assistant that can do almost
anything for you. The second one is team
leverage. So you can turn existing SOPs
into automations really, really easy.
And if you build something new, not just
you can use it, but your entire
organization can. So everyone as a group
is getting way more productive, which
will almost undoubtedly result in growth
of the business. And also monetization.
We're entering this new world where
skills are having a big moment and
you're able to capitalize on a lot of
this stuff. Now, I'm not saying this is
going to be a viable business model for
a long, long time. So, you shouldn't
bank on it, but it is something to be
aware of just like when people were
selling edited in workflow templates and
things like that. But once again, it
just comes down to one word, which is
leverage. This isn't just theory. This
is something that we're seeing with
clients. This is something that we're
seeing internally in my own business.
This speed of work that we're able to
achieve right now feels insane, but that
is going to become normal. And if you
can't do that, you instantly become way
too slow and way too expensive for the
business and they might not keep you
around. We're actually making it a
priority to make sure all of our
employees are using cloud code because
now I have all these different skills
that I can just run with a simple slash
command or a simple natural language
prompt and get in one day a week's worth
of output. Because once again, one
person can figure out the best way to do
something and turn it into a skill that
the entire team can use. But they don't
just generate text. They're basically
automations. They can run scripts. They
can call APIs. They can create things.
They can have sub agents. And they can
be called on from agents as well. So
this is truly AI automation. And just to
really hammer it home, they're basically
SOPs for your AI agents. The same way
where you would train a human employee
by letting them read through an SOP to
understand the process and then they'd
be able to do it. You just train an
agent on it. You give them the skill,
they read it, and then they do it. And
the coolest part about it is the more
you use the skill, the better and better
it gets. So we've talked about a lot of
these benefits, right? But what actually
is a skill? Well, it's just a folder and
it lives somewhere in your project. The
most common example is probably going to
be in your.claude/skills/skillname
and then you've got like a skill MD or a
markdown file. So, right here in my Herk
2 project, you can see up top we've
gotclaude. I open up.claude, we have
agents, rules, and skills. Right now,
we're just talking about skills. If I
open that up, we can see all the
different skills that I've created in.
So, let's say for example, the Excal
diagram skill. If I click into that, we
have a skill.md. And when I open that
up, you can see we have the name of the
skill, the description, and then we have
the actual workflow. Step one,
understand the concept. Step two, plan
the layout. Step three, generate
elements. And this entire skill
basically teaches my agent how to build
these Excal diagrams for me. So, like I
said, that is the anatomy of the skill.
We've got front matter, which is kind of
between these two dotted lines, and that
is in something called YAML, which you
don't need to worry about what that
means. This is just the way that it's
kind of indicated, sort of like your
markdown or your JSON or Python. Now, up
here, we'll have a name and a
description, which tells Claude Code
what the skill is called and what the
skill does. So, as you can see, this one
is called Excalraw- Diagram. And there's
a brief description about what it
actually does or when to use it. And
then we have the step-by-step rules,
which are basically the instructions.
And this is what Claude actually does
once it decides that this is the right
skill for the job. Now the interesting
thing about skills is that sometimes you
need way more data. So for example,
let's say we're writing a LinkedIn post.
We have a skill for that, right? But
what needs to go in the skill is other
information sometimes like a company
tone of voice or maybe your LinkedIn,
you know, tone of voice, a target
avatar, current priorities, a logo.
Maybe there are other things that you
want to put into a skill besides just
like the step-by-step instructions that
will make it better. So the question is,
where do these things go? Well, there's
typically two options, but essentially,
as long as you're pointing to the right
path in the skill.mmd, you're fine. So,
let me explain what I mean by that, and
then I'll show you what I mean by that.
So, first option is to have it
self-contained. So, in
yourcloud/skills/skll
name, you can have the skill.md, you can
have your scripts right there, and you
can have your references right there. Or
option B is that they're not directly
nested right under that skill. So, here
we have.claude/skill/infographic
Claude/skill/infographic
in the skillmd and we still have our
scripts and our references in the same
project but it's just not nested
directly under that skill and so I know
that might have made no sense so let me
show you exactly what I mean by that
okay so here we have a skill called idea
mining and so what happens in here is
basically used when someone asks for
content ideas video ideas what to make
next or to run idea mining and so in
here I gave it some context right my
channel has this many subs it's about AI
automation my content pillars are naden
rag agents cloud odd code, voice AI, and
then what I gave it is a bunch of
references. I gave it channel data,
which is YouTube channel.md. I also gave
it the raw data, which is a JSON file. I
gave it a competitor list for me, and I
gave it an actual script to run analysis
on my YouTube channel. And so in this
case, what you can see is that I went
for option B where I'm storing those
reference files and those scripts, not
directly nested in this skill. So
basically what it could look like is
within the skill itself we could have a
folder called you know references. We
could also have a folder in here called
scripts. And then within both of these
subfolders we could have more things
like you know in the references I could
have channel data. And in the scripts I
could have YouTube-analysis.js
or py whatever it is. Basically the idea
is it doesn't matter where those actual
reference files or scripts live as long
as you point to the right spot in the MD
file. So in my case, where these
actually live is in a different folder.
So here for the channel data, I would
basically just go all the way down to
references and then I could go down to
right here, YouTube channel.md. So cloud
code reads the skill and then it's able
to find this if it needs it. Same thing
for the scripts. It would go down here
to scripts and then it would find
analyze YouTube. py and it would just
pull this in if it needed it. So
hopefully you guys are with me. However
you want to set it up works. And I think
that's the most overwhelming thing about
cloud code right now is that everyone
uses different kind of folder
architecture. But don't worry guys, I'm
totally on top of this. I have a skill
that I built out called skilluer. And
this one I'll be giving away for free
once again in my free school community
right here. And all you'd have to do is
load in the skill builder and then it'll
help you build out everything you need.
And I'll be showing a live demo of that
in a few minutes here. So the skill.md
is the actual brain itself and the
supporting files are the tools that it
can use. That doesn't mean every single
time the skill is invoked that those
reference files will all be called. And
just in case you guys were wondering if
you've watched some of my previous cloud
code videos where we've used the WAT
framework to build automations, this is
very very very similar in that
framework. The W the workflows were the
markdown file SOPs. That's basically the
skill. The tools were the actual Python
scripts and that's basically just the
scripts that you might write or the
references that you would add in. So if
you've already been building some WAT
stuff, you will pick up skills super
super quickly. The cool thing about
skills is that you don't have to build
all of them. Obviously, as you're
working with cloud code and you're
finding that you're doing things
repetitively, you can go ahead and build
a skill for it. But there's an official
library from Anthropic of skills.
There's a community of everyone that's
open sourcing their skills and giving
them out. And there's a marketplace
where you can share and sell or you know
download skills from people. And then
you would take that skill or that
essentially a prompt and you would add
your own flavor to it. The one thing I
would say is just be careful and make
sure that no one's trying to, you know,
give you a skill that has any malicious
intent in there. And all these skills
can work across different products. So,
cursor, anti-gravity, codeex, because
it's so based in markdown and it's
essentially just a prompt, tons of
different AI models can use them. Okay.
So, how does Claude know when to use a
skill? Well, there are two ways to
actually trigger them. The first one is
you can be explicit, which basically
means you can do a slash command and say
the skill name and it will just directly
fire off that skill. Or it could just be
natural language. So if I had a school
post skill, I could say
slashschool-post.
Or I could natural language just say,
"Hey, help me write a school post about
X." Claude would find that skill and
then invoke it. So when you ask Claude
to do something, it will first read
through the cloud. MD file. It will
analyze your request and it will search
through the skills and see which one do
I have that helps with this query. If it
finds one, it will invoke it. But if it
can't find anything, then it will
basically just use its general
knowledge. So not every single request
that you give to cloud code will invoke
a skill. Now a really important part of
that is understanding how skills stay
lightweight because if you've been using
cloud code you know that context
management is a huge deal. And if you
had all of these skills to look through
and all of these skills are I don't know
hundreds and hundreds of lines then if
cloud code was searching through all of
these every single time that would
surely eat up a ton of your tokens. So
what's used is something called
progressive context loading which
basically means we have three levels.
Level one is the initial search where
cloud code only looks for the name and
the description. So right here you can
see let's say we ask for an Excal
diagram. It would basically search
through all the skills but it would only
read the YAML front matter. So it would
read the name and the description. And
typically this front matter is only
going to be you know maybe roughly a 100
tokens. So it stays very lightweight.
And then moving down to level two let's
say it identifies okay cool this is the
right skill for the job. Then it would
run the full skill.mmd and it would read
through everything. And so that's when
it would start to actually understand
what goes on in the skill. And that
might be anywhere from a thousand to a
couple thousand tokens. And then level
three is once again a decision. Only
load in the extra files when needed. So
if I need to look at any scripts or
references or templates or I need to
pull in some brand assets or more
context, I'm only going to do that if
the specific requests requires it. And
so hopefully now you're starting to
understand a little bit more about under
the hood what's actually going on when
you ask cla code to do something for
you. And you can always go to cloud code
docs and go to the skills section and
just read about how this stuff works.
It's really, really simple. On the doc
itself, it will tell you just make sure
to keep the skill.md under 500 lines.
Move detailed reference material to
separate files. And so, I know this may
seem like it's just a lot of information
being thrown at you. So, let me just
kind of contextualize this and slow it
down and reassure you guys. You're never
ever ever going to write a perfect skill
the first try. The way that I build my
skills is I have Claude Code do
something with me. I walk it through the
steps, you know, each time. And then
when we're done, if we've went from
point A to point B, I say, "Cool. This
is something I do once a day. Let's turn
this into a skill. Ask me more questions
so we can make sure you have all the
information you need." And once again,
I'm going to show you guys opening up a
brand new project and setting up a skill
from scratch so you understand the full
process, but I just had to give you guys
some context first. Now, we have this
thing called the feedback cycle, which
basically means you invoke the skill,
you actually watch the agent work, you
give feedback, and then it fixes the
skill, and then you do it again. And so,
the first couple times you run a skill,
you may feel like, eh, this feels very
AI generated. But by the time you've run
that skill 10, 20, 30 times, every
single time it gets better. And so,
that's why it's actually important to
watch the agent work the first couple of
times because that's how you're able to
identify opportunities to speed it up
and save tokens by doing things like
this. So here's an example of the pulse
check skill that we actually ran
earlier. Now this skill gets invoked
when I ask for a pulse check or checking
in on commitments. And what it does is
it reads through some context of how
OTAAS work, which is important for it to
understand every single time it reads
the skill, which is why I put it here
rather than a reference file. And what
it has to do is it has to do a live
lookup on my ClickUp to understand
what's going on. So what I did is I
hardcoded in these list IDs because when
I was watching it, I realized every
single time it was doing this, it was
calling the ClickUp MCP and it was
gathering all these lists and it was
searching and parsing the results and
then it would extract the ID and that
just was taking so long and it was
costing me a ton of tokens. So I
realized that's always going to be the
same. Why don't I just give it in the
skill document the list IDs and now it
knows how to do that instantly every
time and it doesn't waste all those
tokens. And on top of that, I know that
searching through ClickUp can consume a
lot of time and tokens. So, I built a
specialized sub agent that in this
skill, I say, "Hey, delegate to the
ClickUp searcher agent with this query
in order to do all of this searching so
that you don't blow your own context
window." All of that's handled over
there and then you only get the
information that you need. So, there's a
lot of advanced things that you can do
to manage your context. I'm not going to
dive into all of that right now. We're
just focusing on skills, but just wanted
to give you a little taste of what's
possible in the skill.md files. So,
another good example of needing a
reference doc like that is in my skill
builder skill. I obviously use this when
I'm creating new skills, optimizing
skills, auditing skill quality, things
like that. And a lot of the inspiration
I got from this was of course straight
from claude code docs itself about how
to actually use and build and optimize
skills. And so when I was building this
out, I I was watching the agent, you
know, run the skill and I realized it's
searching every single time. It's doing
a web search and it's crawling the
entire document. even if I just need a
little piece of information. So, what I
decided to do was I told it to basically
scrape that whole thing and then I gave
it a reference.md which is basically the
documentation. So, I've got my skill.md
and what it does is it references that
full file if it needs it. But really,
the main idea that I'm trying to drive
home here is that processing markdown
files for your agent is so much quicker
and cheaper than actually making API
calls or HTTP requests, you know,
executing functions and reading tons and
tons of tokens. So the goal is your
skills will get to a place where you can
invoke them, focus on something else for
10, 15 minutes or whatever, and then
come back and have a finished result
that is really, really good. But the
first couple times that you are testing
out a skill, I think it's a really good
idea to just sit there and watch it and
see what it's doing. And a lot of people
have asked me like, when do you know
when to build a skill? Well, basically
just go about your work. And if you ever
realize that you've done something
already or you've instructed something
differently, like I tell my claude to
not use m dashes. Okay, well that's
probably a good idea to put that in the
prompt, right? So, if you ever find
yourself doing a process or repeating
prompts, then that's probably a good use
case to build a skill around it because
skills don't have to be complex. They
could literally just be a 50line
markdown file. All right, so we're about
to hop into a live build of a skill from
scratch, but what I wanted to do real
quick was go over the six-step skill
building framework. So, number one is
the name and the trigger. What is it
called? And the natural language that
would basically fire it off. Number two
is the goal. So, in one sentence, what
will this skill accomplish by the end?
What will be the output? Number three is
the actual meat of it. That's the
step-by-step process. If you had to do
something manually exactly what do you
do in what order? What do you look at?
And what decisions do you make? Number
four is the reference files. What
context do you need? Do you need images?
Do you need understanding of current
projects, current priorities? Do you
need style guides? What do you need to
do the job well? Number five is the
rules. Think about what could go wrong
and then the agent can help you build in
guardrails and constraints around that.
And then number six is kind of like
after you've built it, it's just the
self-improvement loop. And after the
live build, I'm going to talk about
actually testing and iterating and what
you need to do to make them really,
really good. But for now, that's the
sixstep skill building framework. Let's
hop into a live build. Okay, so here we
are in Visual Studio Code, which is
where I like to use Cloud Code. If you
don't have Visual Studio Code, just go
ahead to a browser, type in VS Code, and
then go ahead and download this. This is
what it will look like. If it's your
first time using cloud code in here, you
just have to go to extensions on this
lefth hand side, type in cloud code, and
then install this and then log in with
your paid anthropic subscription. Now,
after that, you're going to click on
this top left button, and it's going to
pull up this little thing that says you
have not yet opened a folder. What you
need to do is open up a project to work
in. So, you could either open up one
that you're already working on, or you
could go ahead and create a new folder,
and then open that one up. For the sake
of the demo, I just opened up a new
blank folder called a bunch of skills.
And I'm going to show you exactly what
to do. So, the first step is to go to my
free school community link in the
description. Go to the agent skills
classroom and download the skilluer
folder. Once you've got those files
ready to go, first thing we want to do
is just set up this workspace real
quick. Initialize this project with a
simple.cloud/skills
structure. Cool. So, as you can see,
that got set up. We have aclad. We have
a skills folder. And what I'm going to
do is in this skill folder, I'm going to
create a new folder called skill dash
builder and hit enter. And then I'm
going to take those two files from my
school community, the reference and the
markdown, and I'm going to put that
right in here. So now we have this skill
builder set up with the reference file
and the actual skill markdown. I'm
asking it if it can see that new skill
that I just added. It says yes, I can
see it. And I'm basically just going to
say, cool, let's run that skill to build
a new one together. So now you can see
what it did is it basically is reading
the skill right now. This is the
instructions that we saw right in here.
As you guys know, since that's how
skills work, it starts to read this. So,
here we go. I built this skill to
actually ask you questions so that it's
way easier for you to communicate what
you want. So, the first thing is what
problem are you trying to solve? What we
want to do is content creation because
in this skill, what I want to do is
building branded infographics. What kind
of content does the skill create? What's
the specific use case or workflow? And
I'm actually just going to choose other
for this. And I'm going to say
educational infographics. Now, it's
asking how we should trigger this skill.
So, does it want to be natural language
or do we want to just use slash
commands? And I'm just going to say both
is fine. And now we're moving on to the
step-by-step process, which is really
important because at this point, we
haven't told it what text we actually
want to use or anything else about our
business. So, walk me through what
should happen from trigger to output.
And it has some good guesses. But what
I'm going to do is do other and explain
this the way that I want it built. I
will tell you what I want an infographic
about. You will create a concept. You
will make a request to key.ai AI to use
Nano Banana to generate the outline or
sorry to generate the image and you will
also look at the brand guidelines that I
give you so that everything that is
created follows my brand colors and
typography and stuff like that. The
output format that I actually want is a
PNG, not any of this stuff. Does this
need to be conversational or fire and
forget? I'm just going to go fire and
forget. All right. So, how does the Key
AI Nano Banana integration work? Is it
an API call? Yep, we're just going to go
with an API call. And in these options,
you could literally say, I don't know.
Let's try different things, you know,
help me figure out what's best. It's
asking where those brand assets live.
So, I'll put them in a folder. And where
should the generated PNG infographic be
saved? Yeah, sure. Let's start a new
folder called projects. And we'll throw
all of them there. So, it's going to
keep our project organized as well. So,
now it's asking about brand guidelines.
I created this folder and I put in our
kind of color scheme as well as the
actual AIS logo. I have put in both our
AIS brand guidelines and the AIS logo. I
want to make sure that in the top left
corner of every single infographic
that's created, the AIS logo appears
exactly as I've given you. But I think
you guys get the point here. I'm going
to answer a few more questions and then
I'll just show you when we have a
result. And now that we've done that,
what you can see is it is going to
create the skill. It's going to create
the logo overlay. It's going to create a
supporting reference markdown file for
all of the API details that it's going
to need. So that's great. It's going to
register the skill in claw.md and it's
going to log its decisions. All right,
so it fully built the skill. It created
all those files for us. We just have to
give it a key API key so we can actually
run this. Okay, so I threw in my API key
and then I said test it out with an
infographic about cloud skills. That's
it. No other context. It invoked the
skill right here and we will see what
happens. Okay, this is really
interesting. So what it's doing is it is
generating the image and then it's just
going to overlay the logo. So it's going
to be a lot more consistent than giving
the AI image generator Nano Banana my
logo. So I didn't even tell it to do
that. Let's see how it looks. Okay.
Well, I don't love this. We're just
going to go back and ask it to change
some things. The logo on the top left
doesn't look great. I gave you a logo
with a transparent background, so it
should just be overlaid on top and we
should be able to see the background
behind it. The actual infographic itself
is all right, but I actually want these
to always be one by one aspect ratio.
Okay, so I made some suggestions and
it's going to try again and it's going
to update its skill. So, we'll see if
that's better. All right, so second time
we run the skill. Let's see if it's any
better. All right, there we So, we've
got the logo up top. We've got cloud
code skills, custom AI workflow, command
prompt, trigger, front matter, config
triggers, AI agent delegation, document
output. So, just keep in mind, all we
said was build an infographic about
cloud skills. And this was run number
two. Every single time that we do this
cycle, remember we talked about the
feedback, we would basically watch it
again, give more feedback, and then keep
going. And after we run this probably
five or six more times, this would be
really, really good. And then every time
I ask for an infographic, it's going to
be consistent. And just to show you guys
what was actually built, if we open up
the infographic builder skill, we have
the actual skill itself. So we have the
front matter right here, the name, the
description, we've got what the skill
does. We've got context. So here's where
it links to the actual brand guidelines
and logos. We've got the step-by-step
workflow right here. And we can see
right here for full API reference and
parameters, just see the markdown file
so that you don't have to actually go
search the web and search through a
bunch of tokens. You can just read this
markdown file. All right. All right, so
we've talked about a lot of stuff about
skills today and we just built one live.
So what I want to talk about now is
really how do you bridge the gap from
like a 90% good skill to making it
pretty much 100%. So testing, iterating,
and debugging. There's different
symptoms and there's different fixes. So
let's just kind of go down this list one
by one. The first symptom might be it
does the wrong steps or in the wrong
order. Well, you would just tell it to
edit the skill.md instructions. You
could get missing tone, style, or
context. In that case, you're going to
add reference files. And of course,
those have to be pointed to correctly in
the skill. MD. You could get the same
mistake happening over and over, then
you're going to add a rule. If it
struggles with a tool or an MCP or it
keeps searching for the same things,
then create some sort of reference dock
for it. If it works good, but it could
get better, then that just means you
have to brute force it. You have to just
run it over and over and over and keep
nitpicking at what it does wrong, or
maybe not wrong, but what it could
improve on. If the skill isn't
triggering, then check the YAML and make
sure it is specific enough. If the skill
triggers too often, then maybe try
disabling model invocation. And that is
something that you can see in the claw
docs, which basically gives you control
over if the skill can only be invoked by
natural language or only be invoked by
the slash command directly, or both. So,
like I said, if you want to look at some
more advanced stuff, then definitely
head over here to the actual doc. But at
this point, we've covered almost
everything about these skills. One thing
that I would call your attention to is
the actual front matter reference
because we saw the name and the
description, which is what's required
every time, but there's lots of other
things that you can add in there. Here's
the disable model invocation like we
just saw. But you can also give it
allowed tools. You can also give it an
argument hint. You can give it a
specific model to use. You can give it
specific context. You can give it hooks.
You can give it a specific agent. And so
all of this lets you get really, really
granular on the exact skill and how you
want it to be used. But don't get
overwhelmed. You really only get to that
point once you've ran the skill a ton of
times. Now, another thing that I need to
hit on real quick is where do skills
actually live? because what we've seen
so far is just building them right in
ourcloud/skills folder. But when you're
doing this, they only exist in that
specific project. So whether that's my
her 2 or my, you know, the one we just
spun up, if I went to a different
folder, that skill would no longer be
able to be accessed by our cloud code.
But you can also create skills that are
actually global. And you do that by
doing that in a different directory in
your kind of overall home directory. And
that's basically indicated by the little
tilda right here. And so that means
every product you use in cloud code, no
matter where you are, that skill would
exist. So for example, I have a
front-end design skill that is installed
globally so that whenever I'm anywhere,
if I need to do front-end design, it
just is able to use it. And just in case
you want to look at it in a different
way, right now what we're doing is we
have our projects, right? So herk 2 and
then we havecloud and then within
dotcloud we have skills and then your
skill and then your MD, your references,
whatever, and then maybe another skill.
But if it was global, you might not
actually see it in your project. It
would just be within your overall home
directory. So the reason why you might
want to do this is if there's something
very specific about you, your business,
your workflows that you want applied to
every single project, no matter what,
maybe your company context, your company
projects, your tone of voice, whatever,
then you can install that globally
instead. If you guys love nerding out
about this kind of stuff, then
definitely check out my paid community.
The link for that is also down in the
description. We've got a great
community, over 3,000 members in here
who are building with AI every day and
building businesses with AI. So, I'd
love to see you guys in this community.
But that's going to do it. So, if you
learned something new, please give it a
like. It definitely helps me out a ton.
And as always, I appreciate you guys
making it to the end of the video. I
will see you on the next one. Thanks
everyone.